I'm really happy to see you too I really
have I am happy to see you too yeah you
are technically still Conan's assistant
is that true or not technically still
Yes okay technically you know what I've
worked with her for so long that I just
can't detach completely yeah so I would
say in a week I would do maybe one or
two things for him okay David does
everything else so that justifies my
existence so you're more of a figurehead
assistant
kind of I mean I still you know want to
make sure he's okay I still like right
now he asked me to lunch and I was like
oh yeah I have to go to lunch to go that
was being the assistant I don't know
him yeah that's me working here oh it's
City yeah I don't know how do you dip in
like another juicy all the email
requests for stuff he needs done and
you're like I'll do that one no people
still email me not not realizing I'm not
as assistant
[Music]
look I'm doing something so right is
that what you say in the email look I'm
doing something yeah that's all she
writes yeah
existence is your assistant but I don't
think I could ever I I know this sounds
sad but I can't ever stop being his
assistant wow I don't know why I I
really love that job home syndrome
that's this is really an intervention
we're gonna
extract you from a very messy I really
like this job I really have fun with
this job it's fun well it has morphed
into so much more than an assistant
you're now a co-host of his podcast yeah
yeah but you know that could all go away
and then what's left
yeah I guess you go back to picking up
dry cleaning
or writing more
New York Times bestseller books right
one week
yeah on the best seller list and then
you can say I'm in New York Times
bestselling that that never goes away
everything changes too you're in better
placement in stores which I didn't know
yeah yeah it's very exciting and then
you could just brag about it to
everybody but oh yeah well that's the
key yeah yeah why does it why do
anything if you can't brag about it
right that's the only point I know I
don't I I keep thinking like how do I
introduce myself to people and I think I
still introduce myself as Conan's
assistant I don't think I can ever be
like I'm on a podcast and I wrote a book
I'm an author yeah I'm an author people
no you don't have to tell them what you
do people I mean you get tons of love
for the podcast I don't know I don't I
don't pay attention no but I I just mean
when you're out and about you're smart
though yeah well yeah that's true
which is cool yeah that's fine well I
feel like people recognize you a lot
more after the Conan and Armenia show
which is Jesse what a nice really
beautifully done thought we might bring
you on to talk about that I'm happy I
have I I think that show changed so much
for me that's that's why one of the
reasons we wanted to talk about it and
also yes this season where we're kind of
focusing in on Conan outside of the
studio studio out and about yes remotes
I feel like you could do like 15 Seasons
just on his remotes right that's the
plan are you listening serious
serious
yes we we wanted to talk about the big
trip to
beautiful Armenia yeah so that was our
second Conan Without Borders show yes
after Cuba and how did that come about I
know that Sweeney you were involved in
pitching that way before that it's funny
how things happen organically especially
with Conan like in 2012 when he was
doing a clueless gamer with blay and he
wore a Yerevan t-shirt yes and that led
I'm assuming you gave him that I did
give him that right you gave him that
shirt the capital of Armenia yes thank
you and
um you you got an email from something
called Yerevan magazine yes they had
seen the clueless game right and they
saw Conan they were writing to thank him
for wearing that shirt yeah and they
wanted to make him an honorary like the
Irish Ambassador uh -huh to the Ukraine
and they they invited him
to visit Armenia so that was the initial
that seed of inviting them completely
forgot about that and this oh sorry that
was to say it's how excited people get
whenever they see Yerevan on anything
and seeing it on Conan O'Brien it's huge
yes yeah for my people is there someone
whose whole job it is to just watch all
TV and look for mentions of Yoruba there
doesn't even I mean I think if I think
everyone has like a detection it's like
oh there's a yetavon shirt on someone
who's not Armenian and then they just
find it and then they spread it around
to everybody just like make sure you
yeah yes
well whenever I meet someone from our
media and I say oh I've been to EuroVan
they're like
why
it's like guys
this isn't the right attitude to have
about your country Oh no you're not
Armenian what were you doing there it's
like well it is an Open City yeah anyone
can visit
you know and I started and then I say no
I we loved it I had a wonderful time and
they started arguing with me you know
it's just like well I think because most
Armenians now don't live in Armenia
right no we're most of us live outside
yeah diaspora yeah it is it is and uh my
husband's from Armenia you know I might
talk because of the show we wanted it we
wanted to yes can you tell us the story
well we went to Comic-Con for or you
know we do a week of shows there and
then I was leaving on a late train on
Sunday so I was like let me just go to
Comic-Con yeah and I've met him on the
floor through a mutual friend and then
he's like I know you you went to Armenia
with Conan and I go yeah and then that
opened up a conversation and then two
years later we were married well and
it's so great because part of so part of
the premise of Co of Conan taking Sona
to Armenia was he wanted to do a
matchmaking service yes right to
introduce you to an Armenian a nice
Armenian man
um that would make your grandmother
happy yes and uh it kind of worked out
that way yeah indirectly you didn't meet
anybody in Armenia on that trip but as a
result of the show you eventually did
yeah well you guys also set up this
Matchmaker in Armenia and I had
absolutely no idea then we go over there
yes
no you're you guys are so proud of
yourself do you I don't I
honestly I'm proud of yourself you're
like oh my God you dicks it was probably
your idea sweetie no I don't think so
not at all no the whole idea the premise
Like Jesse said of the show part of it
was that your parents and your
grandparents wanted you and so and also
Conan was going to bring gifts back for
your parents like they wanted to visit
with them and and they gave us a
shopping list and one of the things
besides a nice rug and Etc was a husband
for you yeah yeah that's all Yaya wanted
my grandma your grandma yeah she did it
I think she knew who Conan was but
didn't care there were cameras she's
like this is a new person for me to tell
that I want my granddaughter to be
married if while I'm in Armenia
I meet a nice Armenian man
do you want me to encourage this man
she says I'm going to say it now I want
her to get married
you want her to get married yes you know
it's really sweet I don't want to bring
it down but you know that aired in
November and Yaya died in December and
so having that on film was really
special and then six months later I met
Tech so you know I mean it kind of
worked
so you met taxed literally the the
following summer after this yes wow so
yeah wow and what did he did he did he
say he'd watch the show and yeah he said
he watched it because he grew actually
grew up in Armenia he was he's a former
Soviet oh wow wow yeah he speaks Russian
oh cool that seems useful
I don't know
yeah we were talking Mila Kunis was on
Conan needs a friend recently and we
were talking about these Soviet toys
that we have that our kids play with
right and we have we have stuffed
animals that you squeeze and they sing
things in Russian and it's very like tax
like oh it's my childhood and I'm like
this is very off-putting wow
seems pretty great you haven't seen the
Americans have you yeah
I know I know
does he disappear for hours
really bad wigs that anyone could tell
yeah yeah he does he has a collection of
passports and different IDs
kids play with it
uh no that was uh yeah that trip was
meant so much I I've always wanted to go
to Armenia yeah I was wondering and that
was something that in the back of your
mind you thought okay someday I'll get
to go and you just you know it had the
opportunity hadn't Arisen yet well no so
I went to an Armenian private school
near Montebello and I went there until
10th grade and then I left but their
senior year trip is always to Armenia so
had I stayed I would have gone with my
senior class yeah and all my friends had
gone and I just didn't I didn't go so
that was always kind of a regret
probably right that you missed or
definitely not regret for leaving this
no oh no I just been missing this the
trip definitely I was really bummed to
miss it I had huge fomo because it is
one of those it's like everybody wants
to go to Armenia at some point you know
and just kind of go there it's like a
giant Glendale so it's really really
right
there's a Cheesecake Factory
hey 38 car washes in one block I'm back
home in Glendale
oh so many track suits I can say it I
can say it yeah you can I can laugh I
could say too so many tractions okay oh
no I'm in trouble I guess that's really
disparaging oh my God yeah no I don't
know how many people know about the the
giant Armenian
uh
despora
diaspora yeah the diaspora it took a
long time to get that out I don't know
how to pronounce words the diaspora
that's one of those words I'm always
terrified to see oh yeah uh because I
don't know how to say it yeah yeah I
think you tried every version of it
right there so yeah
that was a journey
[Laughter]
so yeah I mean what were your
expectations going did and how were they
how were they met when you when you
actually landed I'm not gonna lie I
think because growing up you heard about
how they were recovering from the Soviet
Union there would be no electricity
sometimes there was no running water so
I thought I was going to like a third
world country yeah and when we got there
Yerevan is like a really kind of Buster
yeah modern city so I was really
surprised about that I um
I was surprised at how little I
understood their dialect oh interesting
um because it's I speak Armenian but I
speak Western Armenian they speak
Eastern and it's a very different
dialect is it actually different or is
it it's just the accent is different no
the the like sentence structures
different some of the words are
different and they have a lot of Russian
in their Armenians so I've learned it a
lot more now that I'm married to tack
but I I when I was there I had no idea
what a lot of people were saying would
you pick up on that now that once you
came back here that like oh they're
they're
yes eastern western yeah yeah you can
tell you can tell who's from who's which
Armenians are from Iran which Armenians
are from Beirut you there's just
different like yeah they all have
different words they use yeah yeah Latin
America's that way was Spanish there's
like different yeah there's just
different slang in every single country
in South America yeah and and syntax
yeah I think that's just how it is yeah
like my parents are from Istanbul and
they use a lot of Turkish words and when
they speak Armenian but you know I don't
know I think
I think you do know
she was fascinated in Yerevan it's
everything was so new because it was all
built like since in 1989 yeah basically
it felt like even though the city is
really old but so many of the buildings
uh are post-soviet yes yeah they are
they are yeah it was on the old Silk
Road that uh you know so it was an old
going back to ancient Greece it was kind
of a crossroads for trade and everything
so
see I didn't even know that you know so
much more about her because you guys do
so much so I just made that up try to
fill area here you guys really do I I'll
say this because I've mentioned this
before when I've talked about this
episode is I'm the only Armenian person
who was involved with the show and so it
was I was almost like what if they say
something that's just gonna offend my
entire community and then I'm just
completely ousted and of course the
opposite happened and I think it's a
testament to you guys uh and the
researchers and everybody who's involved
in editing it how you made a show about
a culture that people in the culture are
very proud of oh that's so nice and it's
and it's really it really is it's
amazing how you guys do that you've done
that with every country you've gone to
where you've it's you know we cut out a
lot of yeah yeah that stuff's available
and we'll put that we have a separate
website yes if you want to be offended
if you subscribe
join our Elite service yeah well I know
especially Armenians they're they hold
their breath to see how people will
address the genocide question right and
the fact that Conan said it and talked
very openly about it and we went to the
memorial he just became a God to
Armenians after that I I thought there
was a just a beautiful segment and I was
I did like being on Commercial
television or where there's commercials
like it was actually after five acts of
Comedy right you came back and just went
into this serious segment about you
visiting the the memorial yeah which was
I think I always found it very moving
and beautiful well I I think also we
were walking around I there were all
these City I mean I hadn't gone to it
before but there were all these Villages
that were affected by it and I knew my
grandparents what was my grandparents
Village was affected by it but I was
like what if it's not etched in stone
what if I can't find it and then when we
found it that was like oh wow it just
became so much more real I remember that
when you when you found that on the wall
there and it was yeah yeah how was that
for you I mean because I was very aware
of like this is this is you were really
going through some real emotions and
then also so you know you're there with
your boss and it's all kind of being
filmed like was any of that in your head
or were you just really in the moment
and experiencing it I I tried not to uh
pay attention to the cameras I think I
don't like to be aware of myself when
I'm doing anything I don't want to like
be like oh I gotta do things at the
Holocaust Memorial
I hope they don't give me funny hats
here
it's just what those two would do but it
is it is something that hit me I was
like oh my God I'm in Armenia with Conan
O'Brien what happened that this is my
life right now it is really strange that
that even that's how you ended up
visiting right yeah we started sticking
it out with that high school I thought
you hated in Montebello I thought you
were kicked out of it
no I
I those moments where I was like okay
you know you get an idea of where you've
come from and where you are and both of
those kind of like it came to a head
there and it was crazy it was just crazy
you can't think about it too much like
you said no it just it doesn't make
sense anyway so why right it is hard to
process yeah but I understand that but
also you have always
you're one of those people I get so
jealous of because you said I don't
really pay attention to the camera you
are not self-aware and I think that is
such a gift that you have in such a time
oh it's fine you're fantastic always
well I think it's uh like I just you
know it's even with the podcast I'm like
if this goes terribly it's not my name
yeah no but that's I have nothing right
because I also you know I don't want to
be a performer so if it doesn't go well
it doesn't matter and I think there's
something really kind of liberating
about not having anything to lose
those weekly lunches
tax deductible man it must be so
infuriating there's so many people in La
that come here like uh just dying just
dreaming of getting on camera
phone is like I don't care I don't wanna
I don't want to be here I guess I'll do
it and it seems the more I don't care
the higher I go oh look at me I'm sorry
everyone else look at that sorry
everyone waiter and wait for us don't
assist anymore yeah I guess on the
podcast I don't know
were there points I I just recently
rewatched Conan and Armenia uh Conan and
Sona in Armenia
um were there points where you were it I
really love the dynamic you have where
he's kind of like your dad and sort of
you know like embarrassing you a lot in
front of people yeah did you ever
actually feel embarrassed of him I mean
we we went out a lot into like
I don't know there we went to a a like a
flea market yes you know haggling with
people and picking really erotic
paintings how much
I'll go higher oh my God I'll give you
200 American dollars oh my God tell him
but he originally asked for a hundred
dollars and I'm saying I'm gonna give
him 250 dollars okay guys I want to meet
the girl where's the girl
you sick freak
oh God I guess I just wonder like yeah I
do think you know part of the process is
him just doing a lot of bits off camera
too yes and there were moments off
camera where I was just like I just want
to take this in I don't need a bit all
the time I never talk about this because
I I don't want to like you know offend
Conan but they're especially all the
bits that happened like there was a
police escort yes we had a police escort
the entire time we were there like we
were dignitaries and so right you know
he made a lot of fun with it and I'm
looking out the window I'm like just
shut up I'm trying to look at the
Armenian legendary side yeah like just
just stop with the bits and let me take
this in but it's his it's what he does
it's like he can't stop yeah if this
wasn't on camera it would still be
happening I think I think this is the
truth it does yeah but I mean actually
shooting stuff no I thought everything
we did was just a lot of fun I didn't
really like when other people around are
laughing then you just don't really care
as much that you know he's doing
something that might be embarrassing
because he's only embarrassing himself
right right yeah and Armenians I mean
they seemed to have a really good sense
of humor about everything yeah yeah like
they picked up quickly I mean and part
of it might just be that Conan looks so
funny to begin with I think I think
that's how it is when we go anywhere is
that right the way he looks is in such
Contra like there are people who can tan
and they have dark hair you know and
then there's this giant white man and
yeah and he's acting like a big goof and
they don't know who he is yeah and
they're just like okay we'll just let
this guy Scream in the middle of this
market and you know I watch that again
and I'm just like
he's like ah now that's the food of my
people and he picks up a potato and he
just goes potato yeah in this giant
Warehouse
potato
yes I was like oh wow I can't believe he
just I I forgotten they just yelled that
but then he just kept yelling it for
five minutes yeah and then you know when
you're when you're there making the show
you're like this is you're gonna get
those reactions yeah right right get
cutaways get cutaways I know what I
think is fascinating too which nobody
sees when they watch these specials is
there's the cameras and then there's a
group of people behind like you guys and
Jason and like the the local crew the
local producers all just kind of huddled
around and the way everybody just sort
of stays out of this shot is always so
fascinating to me hopefully that's our
biggest fear is like one of those things
where all of a sudden someone's like
move and you're like yeah him in
the shot I'm in the shot in the chat and
sometimes I'll just turn and pretend
like I'm a boss
pick up an orange that guy turns up at
every location and then turns and walks
away I know well I remember when we went
to the matchmakers house she just kept
presenting one guy after the other that
had all these big red flags shooting
fish in a barrel just and everybody was
dying and we were in this house I
remember being crouched under like under
her desk or something yeah I was really
I was crouching hiding and trying not to
laugh out loud because we're kind of in
her study living room and it was we had
our equipment there so there wasn't a
lot of places to hide yeah oh my she
just kept showing one guy she had like
80 guys she's like do you want to look
at more and we're like yeah
we'll cut it down and yeah they were
like from age 17 to 82. yeah right yeah
all red flags 25 years old oh that's not
a problem she likes young men I like
that clearly he he went to Harvard
and I think
oh those shorts are a problem what
happened in these jeans that looked like
he had bottles of white out in his
pocket and they exploded what happened
oh that's good that shows that he likes
nature or maybe he's I don't
know he doesn't even take his pants down
[Laughter]
during that seg was any part of you
actually like let me check these guys
out
I was like it would be nice to like meet
somebody and then it you know again none
of them really were viable suitable yeah
right right what about other just around
Yerevan were there ever any like fans
that came up and and you thought oh I
don't know maybe you know what uh on my
birthday dinner the server at my
birthday
yes I remember that he was lighting
those cognacs on fire man you know you
were you had to drink it and it was
flaming oh right it was like flaming
going down your throat yeah that's true
yeah that was a really fun dinner
because we were eating like plates of
lamb yeah and then flaming cognac right
I was glad I didn't throw up I know I
got pretty wasted I don't think I drank
the Flaming I'd remember a flame going
down my throat yeah I feel like I feel
like you did you just didn't notice
everybody did everybody on the table had
to like you got probably pressured into
it yeah yeah maybe
oh so that guy was hot yeah there was a
whole I remember we kind of were like
maybe trying to get his number or
something he wasn't into it yeah he
might have been gay I don't know he
could have been yeah yeah there's no
other logical explanation
[Laughter]
we solved that mystery it's worth
waiting back in
yeah oh my God you know what I remember
how didn't we I mean it was pretty much
going halfway around the world I
remember getting into that hotel and we
had to hit the ground running yeah this
morning and shoot yes and I I like I was
like I've got to wake up I I did the job
that's a really long flight because we
went yeah over the North Pole yes right
there's like an Emirates flight to Dubai
to Dubai and then to Yerevan yeah
it was you know and I people asked me
how long we were there thinking we were
there for weeks yeah and I think we were
there for two and a half three days yes
was it really that easy no way three
full days I think I think so yeah three
or five full days of just shooting oh
wow yeah so much and then Conan was on
three shows too yeah he was on two late
night shows you guys played like Flip
Cup oh my God
I remember getting drunk the whole time
I really was and I was like I'm home you
know those sis is home this makes sense
that TV house was kind of cute too
you know what there were two guys that
were uh the host of a show the arm
comedy show and I kept in touch with
both of them that's nice they came to
visit the show in L.A they did I kept in
touch yeah but the one that we played
flip cup I did not I I was like I'm out
yeah I can't and then one of my favorite
things ever Conan we we started doing
this on all the coding Without Borders
travel shows I was trying to get them on
local soap operas yeah like the more
serious to show the better like they'd
always I I think the the countries would
always pitch Conan on a comedy show and
it's like yeah but but just put him in a
drop serious actor
with gravitas we're filling out his
resume yeah but that outfit for The
Armenian soap opera they put a black wig
on them and then they dyed his eyebrows
black which and he looked like Richard
kind yeah they tried everything to make
him as Armenian yeah
it was so with that shot where you I I
watched again the camera starts on on
him and his goons but it starts on their
feet and it pans up to see Conan and
he's just like with a cigar you know and
I I don't know if you remember but I
invited 20 people to that table I don't
remember that and and you were and you
and and rightfully so you and Conan too
hate when it's a big group from all the
same people like it's you know if it's
like a group of like 20 people it can
disrupt the taping I feel like you guys
don't right we'll try to keep it tiny
footprint yes around yeah well no no
when we uh when we aired the show for
the for the audience in L.A all right
yeah which gave it the the soundtrack
you found out right before we were about
to show the show uh that I had 20 people
and you you met a lot of them and you're
like you guys gonna laugh
[Applause]
I wasn't worried about them but but no
that's an old thing and like back in New
York and just when you have
a studio audience
you don't want ideally you don't want a
big group yeah of like 12 the same group
because they tend if they're not good
that's 12. it's as if you've just
eliminated 12 seats in the audience does
that make sense no I I agree with you
nobody from the group will laugh as a as
an outlier right like No One's Gonna
laugh on their own or maybe they'll be
great but but if they're if they're not
a good group yeah and and sometimes
groups tend to be yeah they have the
same sensibility right yeah it's a
bachelorette party and they're not
exactly they're not fans yeah yeah they
have a different agenda for being there
so yeah yeah I know I I remember and I
was like oh my God I did I invited 20
people and I should have known better no
but that was luckily they were laughing
there was a show about Armenia we
specifically for that like for when we'd
screen the travel shows we always
whatever we'd put a call out for people
from the yeah whatever country we're
going to so that was perfect yeah well
and also I think because they saw my
grandparents and they all knew them and
they were just no it's great and I I
think I remember they lost it when they
saw Conan in the the soap just because
they know Armenian soap operas and Conan
try to pass off as being Armenian I had
one line of dialogue right that's all he
had one word yeah what word
yeah
smoking a cigar I loved that show that
was a rude people still bring it up to
me all the time they do yeah it's been
what was that 2015 yeah and people still
bring it up to me yeah what was the
reception like when people first saw it
were you just getting bombarded yeah I I
think I've been to every Armenian
fundraiser that you could possibly go to
yeah you like got the key to Glendale
yeah it was so much
I sat I that was huge
uh the I didn't know this but Armenians
have a float in the Rose Parade every
year oh cool and they asked me if I
would be on the Rose Parade so I went at
like four in the morning and went and
sat on a on a float for I think like six
hours I have no idea right in the
beginning you're like this is so
exciting and then like by hour three
you're like oh okay 4 20 a.m
my hand hurts from waving I'm in
Pasadena it was so fun though that was
really cool and also now you know we're
getting
so my husband and I we have our twin
boys and we're looking at preschools
yeah my Soviet husband and we're looking
at preschools and we're thinking about
sending them to Armenians really and
some of them have wait lists the one in
Montebello there's there's a actually we
were like are there any near where we
live and there's like three there's I
mean there's a million of us that are
everywhere
um but it it does help to just be like
uh you know I don't know if you know
this but can you just uh slip a DVD copy
yeah
DVD maybe this will change your mind
wait list you say here's this uh episode
I was in with a Conan O'Brien my kids
are very poorly behaved but check out
this seat
they throw their feces around to
everyone but look at this episode
yeah yeah so you you I mean it's kind of
like being a celebrity yeah Armenian
celebrity it is I mean you know we uh
there's there's not not a lot of
Armenians who are in the public eye you
know but just to also be I mean
I guess uh a little bit famous
um but then it drops off after that
and then soda yeah basically yeah it's
it's just it's nice it's it's nice to be
part of that community and I grew up in
the community I like you know I I grew
up going to Armenian schools I got
married in the Armenian Church like it's
a big part of who I am and to have had
that episode and also for Conan you know
a lot of Uber drivers are Armenian right
and every single time he's in a car with
an Armenian he's like I've been to
Armenia and they've almost always seen
the episode he doesn't even have to tell
them no yeah how did your family like
watching the episode oh they loved it
and I think it really meant a lot to my
dad especially that you know I talked
about his family yeah his parents who
were both orphans because of it yeah
they think and I I um uh it's I I just
just I I think everybody was just really
happy with how it turned out and how
proud of how fun it was yeah and they're
they were really proud of of that I was
first of all they've been very proud
that I work for Conan really yeah I
think that you know everybody in my
family knows who he is and knew who he
was before I started working for him and
then when I started working for him and
then they found out he was just a nice
person that was another and then you
know my when my grandma passed away in
December I mean Sweeney you came to her
funeral which meant a lot and and Conan
came to my parents house and and so it's
you know they I think that more even
than the episode the fact that I work
with all these non-armenians who are
just so kind and nice and very
understanding of our of our community
and our culture it means a lot to them
so that's really sweet you know it was
really sweet that you did that oh of
course yeah well I she was adorable she
was so sweet it was really cute yeah
she's really sweet I didn't know you did
that Sweeney that is nice I'm not gonna
try I wore my best sweatsuit
I had to ruin it
I know I know he warmed up the crowd I
warmed up the crowd uh no more than 10
people allowed at this funeral you guys
are gonna laugh right oh it's
a funeral
no it was really she let me also came
like a lot of people from the show you
know came in that was really should let
me you'll find she let me in me at a lot
of funerals
to see you there
it doesn't matter who they are have we
met them she let me and I are there
every Friday morning
we're a couple of creeps sometimes you
know funeral Crashers
[Music]
oh my God your husband seemed like a
great man but are you ready to step up
oh so we came and so we came back with
speaking of your grandmother and uh and
your parents we brought some gifts back
for them yeah and one of them was that
painting yes
it's not erotic she's not but it's a
little it always reminded me of um
Tiffany Amber Thiessen from Saved by the
Bell that's why I see when I see that
painting okay yeah yeah I see it is that
still hanging in their house it never
hit hung in their house it was under the
bed and it's always been under the bed I
mean
yeah but they they didn't throw it out
of course because that would incur the
curse
oh yes I think it would have much more
of a purpose Conan's building I agree
yeah yeah yeah he should have to deal
with the concert
[Laughter]
oh
oh I would think those would Age better
better than the painting the way they
look no they were really excited we
opened that bottle of cognac that way
why don't we drank it that day I mean
yeah yeah everybody brought that waiter
back to sit it on fire
that's what he learned he was gay
just just to open that bottle and set it
on fire it was fun I loved meeting your
family and I and they were just as good
on camera as you are because everyone's
so natural yeah like no one's thinking
too much about the cameras being there
or what you know what it's gonna look
like yeah what their good side is yeah I
know they're they're not those people uh
they were really nervous though about
were they saying something stupid oh
really yeah I mean you know they seems
so yeah like Jesse's saying so
inflappable yeah but they I think that
they I mean they hit it well or they
just kind of like once once Conan
started talking they're like okay you
know he's gonna he's mostly gonna
attract right and we'll occasionally get
to China will not yeah yeah but also
that uh language teacher she also seemed
really just sort of
yeah Conan took a language well the
first segment was called which he often
does is like I'm going to new country I
need to be armed with some of the the I
have to learn some language so you can
survive yeah oh and those were I mean
she had great because she was teaching
him some local phrases yeah
I die on your body yeah yeah and then he
was doing using those then we cut to him
in the market
udem
[Applause]
Maryland
and
people I was like oh there's no way no
anyone's Gonna Know It Right these are
and he was killing yeah he was yeah now
he just like he only
remembersek yeah yeah which is hello how
are you and he says that to everybody
teen languages yes he said he when he
gets in an Uber he says it automatically
automatically I'm from Ireland whatever
you're getting my Armenian
what does
I'll eat your or I eat your liver I eat
your liver you should get it through
that what you get is like a did you get
is how you say liver okay and it's a
term of endearment like alone it's a
church like you're my liver
um but yeah that's how a lot of Armenian
words are like uh you know cucumber is
and it's also something you call
somebody who's an idiot like it's a
cucumber a cucumber yeah that's great
it's there's just a lot of things Market
based yeah yeah and they're very intense
like one of it is Hokies like you're my
soul you know but that's just really
nice but uh did you get it this is very
there's a lot of passionate yeah
undertones they're like it yes yeah and
it's like I eat your gallbladder is that
more formal or is that a little like
let's let's you know
is less formal very less formal because
you don't need it
yeah any vestigial I was just thinking
why has there not been an Armenian
Bachelor has there been uh
yeah they are usually except that one
who was yeah uh Latino but then one
black guy there was right I stopped
watching after like after we talked
about it when we were in 48. we were
hurting sheep right we talked about the
new season coming out with with Ben and
then I actually met him last week yeah
and I wanted to be like I talked about
you when I was herding sheep in Armenia
but I didn't say it no no I didn't
it seems like a natural segue where'd
you meet him what's he doing this is
gonna sound so corporate no I went to
some uh it was an advertising panel for
auto advertising and podcasts
[Music]
okay yeah it doesn't sound corporate at
all that's uh I tried to get into that
but it was sold out sorry I missed that
one I was I didn't want to scalp but I I
almost did stop the ticket
and what a shock he would be there yeah
which one is he in Auto advertising he's
in he's on a podcast so it's all about
Auto advertising on podcasts
specifically so it's very specific it is
oh yeah so you brought up this the
shepherd segment yes because that was
amazing we drove out for I mean hours it
felt yeah yes into the countryside uh
off-road I mean off in these SUVs hours
on main roads and then yes made a hard
like right turn on those those back
roads I thought that was it was scary
yeah that was insane it was and I I
remember it was just downed at like
super really inclined yeah through
switchbacks out there it was like down
down up up up where you thought oh this
Jeep might tip backwards and we couldn't
really communicate we just kept asking
the driver like uh what you know where
we're going and he was just kind of
nodding uh-huh even the police escort
was like
the old Shepherds out there yeah
track suits yeah
six miles all of a sudden there they
were yeah yeah it was it was so cool I
almost beautiful just seeing you know
the mountain like I've seen so many
illustrations of that growing up and to
actually see it in person felt surreal
but then when we're in the in the
countryside you could see it pretty
clearly from where we were I remember
that yeah and then we put on those
ridiculous outfits and then we were from
L.A right from L.A
yeah they were just like
just list her from
yeah yeah no but that was it was uh I
mean we we heard it sheep like that's
just weird it was weird it was so
fascinating though I was like I never
thought I would ever do this in my life
yeah you well we all stayed up on the
hill because it was we shouted very wide
because you want to get the sense of the
valley and and you guys hurting cheap so
what was it like being that do you
remember well because I we were talking
about the bachelor right Conan and I
were far from each other so I was you
know projecting and as I was talking
about it the Sheep are just moving away
off you go now what next a good Bachelor
a guy who's kind of a dick yeah like not
that much drama I mean he wants us he
just won't have that much drama
Sony your natural speaking voice is
driving them that way
just from like us talking to each other
so maybe that's what the other guys were
doing the tracksuit guy that's how you
heard sheep you just speak in your
normal speaking voice and Armenians are
just loud as it is so yeah but it was it
was very like I've never been that close
to a sheep I love that we were there for
three days and we spent probably eight
hours driving out to get a sheep herding
segment you have to get the shot
you gotta get it but then we did get to
go to that place it was like a little
Distillery where they were making apple
vodka and yeah and then we were making
the lavash bread the wash was cool that
was cool that was cool because I've
never seen it made I eat it all the time
yeah but only women can make it yeah
only women can make oh only women can
make it you there's a it's like an
underground oven you sous-vide you get
it yeah
you put it on what's like a pillow and
just smack it against the edge of the
wall right wait till it Cooks just for a
little bit the oven it's that hot yeah
and then just take it out and only women
can can make lavash like it's and it's
true in the like in the U.S too I mean
or what there is a place
yeah there is a place in in Glendale
that does make fresh lavash and I think
it's I think they've stayed true to it I
think it's only women who can like it
like you can't designate it kosher you
know yeah right I had a lot of rules I
don't know but it was so good I wonder
if there's a note on the packaging yes
it lets you know only only or if it's
been sullied by a man's touch yeah but I
remember we ate I was eating that lavash
and then there was like Feta cheese and
some herbs and it was just delicious it
was so simple and it was so good well it
was all girl I mean it was probably
cheese from the Sheep yes yeah yeah yeah
and they were very free
[Laughter]
Terrell
oh my God that was fun and then the
dancers that was another segment I
remember
we are at the Garney Temple it's about
an hour's Drive outside yaravan
[Applause]
I hadn't I didn't get into the dancing
because it was just like seeing it was
were you like I'm gonna sit this one I
think I'm good I'm good here yeah and he
came out in traditional Armenian outfits
yeah well that was one where I remember
sometimes we get nervous because we'll
sign Conan up for things and then it's
like oh he oh no there's a choreographer
who's planning on teaching him like
like 20 minutes of a dance you know or
something really intricate that we're
like oh we don't have time because
Conan's just gonna do it badly on
purpose right so we right we weren't
planning on being here all day and the
instructor's like I spent 30 Years
Learning yeah how to do this do you
think you'll ever go back I I will I
want to go with my kids I want to take
my boys there
um does tax still have any family he
does he has some family that still lives
out there a lot of them came out here
yeah but he still has some family that
lives out there and you know in Yerevan
or in Yerevan oh wow wow yeah so he
still has family that lives there so we
we always talk about it we also you know
we went to Israel too all of us together
and there's an Armenian quarter in
Jerusalem right
um and he's actually we would love to
make it like a trip where we go there
and then go to the Armenian like then go
to Israel and you know just be very Army
Armenian like just yeah every Armenian
spot we could Armenia did up we just pop
up everywhere like we went to to
Bethlehem remember and then there was an
Armenian Church right next to right oh
wow yeah we're just wherever anywhere
anywhere that's even slightly religious
we're like let's go and let's just stay
there and I didn't know that open an
outdoor mall
don't forget the car washes 30.
that's our Armenian guarantee
that was the craziest thing about
Jerusalem I didn't know it was broken
into four quarters yeah and that the
Armenian
three the three biggest religions in the
world right and then Armenians and wow
nobody questions it it's just our little
our little puppy
I know and then you know it's I think
that they're known for tile the most
that in Glendale all right we're good
find a little spot and we'd take over
exactly and then that's it people are
like well they're here they've always
been here and so yeah they just deal
with it I know what's mad about
Armenians having a quarter yeah I don't
think no that was yeah I feel like it's
the least controversial quarter it kind
of is like they make Armenian pizza and
right yeah like that's what they're that
and tiles that's what they're known for
tiles
yeah and so they uh that's that's what
we do in Jerusalem and people are like
all right yeah it's great well that'll
be a fun trip I think and that'll be
cool to bring your kids I know when
they're old enough yeah yeah they're
just like I know you got that that's
you're going to want to bring them when
they're younger but it's good to wait
yeah because sometimes I talk to my kids
now but like I remember we went to
[Laughter]
I know but I'll get texts about this too
you guys don't know how much pressure it
is to show you things correctly oh yeah
well it's it is a lot of pressure to
speak for an entire people yeah which is
why I always make a point to say that
you know I was born yeah for an entire
diaspora
[Music]
and are you gonna teach the boys
Armenian we're speaking to them now oh
yeah and again we speak two different
dialects yeah and when tax parents come
they speak to them in Russian and then
my parents speak to each other in
Turkish in front of them oh my God
they're gonna be like they're never
gonna speak I would be like I don't know
I don't know what's coming out of their
mouths but yeah
I'm gonna use my hands they're just
gonna type emojis to you I'm going to
point yeah two things I want in my mouth
yeah no my my one of my boys already
uses his hands a lot like armies like he
was trying to lift something and his
brother was standing on there and he
went like this like get up like why are
you on there and it's such an Armenian
thing to do I love that and he you know
he just got it from seeing us be like
just talk with our hands a lot that's
great yeah it's pretty great yeah it's
on video it kind of yeah I'll show you
and thank you for naming one of your
twins after me you're welcome wow you
could have gotten mic one and Mike two
but you're getting greedy now yeah you
haven't been doing enough funerals for
that I
I know we named them very traditional
Armenian names Michael and Charles
so very very yeah they're gonna be so
multilingual and then have these yeah
white guy names yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
well my husband tax full name is Art
duck which was the name of one of our
security guards when we were in Armenia
and so everyone calls them Tack and then
my name is Sona but I my first name is
talleen so we were like both of us grew
up just like constantly spelling our
names and so recently I called about
something for one of my boys and they're
like What's his name and I was like
Charles and then it was just like okay
okay how do you spell that and I've
never experienced that before it was so
exciting then I had to spell the last
name so all right
it's my middle name okay yeah my my
dad's mom who was in that Village her
name is Sona well this was this was so
fun I know I'm talking to you guys
you just you want to be on every episode
yeah I'll I will step away yeah sure I
want to be in this building all the time
yes that's what I'm actually asking
right right right yeah so what I mean
what's next for you
do I ever have a plan no I love that you
don't though that's the way to do it I
think it's good to seeing how things go
you know people used to ask I I when I
started in TV I was like I need to do
this I need to do this I need to do this
and then I just got to a place where I'm
like this is fine yeah working for
Conan's fun it's cool I like it I get
paid it's fine so I think after that I
was just like all right I'll I'll do
that I'll go to one I'll go to a sit on
a panel for auto advertising and a
podcast literally anything anyone asks
me I'm like they all do that I'll try
that why not and so you know whatever
comes next uh who knows I'm remodeling
my kitchen right now all right okay you
got a Pinterest yeah no
I love that you're bouncing like I'm
remodeling the kitchen and oh I just was
cast in the lead of a new Independence
that would be plausible too
sure I did I guess I'll do that yeah
they offered me the lead second lead
I'll be the ambassador to Armenia